false trial we're here to talk about
today and it's actually a sequel to a
movie made in the mid 90s called the
hunters what did it feel like stepping
back into the shoes of your character
Backstrom after all this time I think
that was one of the points that it has
been and there is 16 years to go back to
the character and it was very exciting
too because the first one was ending
that he just drove away from the
northern part of Sweden and you don't
know what happened to him so it was a
nice game to play with yourself and what
happened to the character during this
years how did it take quite so long to
do follow-up to it because it kind of it
moves on quite nicely doesn't it very
nice and and a lot of producer wanted to
do a second one but the director said no
because it was that film and I think
every year I got a telephone call from a
journalist that's asking I heard it's
going to be a hunter - yeah I don't know
I said but after about 14 years he said
the director himself is a hunter so he
was sitting up there and in Morton then
this story started to come and how was
it working with shale the director shall
send well again yeah it's not to say
this was the second time for me so so
and we had
I mean Sweden is a small country you
often meet each other but me and shell
we hadn't worked together since the
first one so so it was very nice to go
back and you mentioned he's a bit of a
hunter as well and you have to do a bit
of hunting as well as fishing in the
film don't you how would you rate your
fishing and hunting skill I think it's
one of all the things with the wood with
the hunters movies that every actor has
to be in from the northern part of
Sweden and and you're born with it you
know with the fish fishing the hunting
is not so I have not been a big hunter
but I'm a very good Fisher skills yeah
yeah absolutely obviously even though
your character says I don't know why
we're here doing if we could just get
these fish to the supermarket exactly
exactly and of course you paid lots of
detect
now having young see the hunters now
with false trail or hunters - also in
things like Wallander sebastian Bergman
as well do you find that you've got a
bit of a forensic mind now yourself yeah
it starts to getting out no it wasn't
mostly it was in the nineties it was a
lot of it was the hunters it was
vilandra and also some shrivel volley
and and it was one of the reason that I
said no to not continue with Avalon day
I wanted to do the Henning Mankell books
and then I said no to do some other kind
of films and so on but it all comes back
you know and what does it feel like
playing those kind of detectives do you
find that you kind of have a little kind
of things that you pick up when you're
playing those roles about how to judge
people and to kind of get what you want
out I think it's easier you know on
movie than it is in real life so yeah
but of course it happens a lot when when
you are all thought out on the street
because it happens to me that I'm a
walking and the police is there and they
really say hello you do you good are
they very happy with how you portray
them I don't know but yeah sometimes now
in fourth trial and one of the
characters actually accuses your
character Erik of of not trusting his
instincts and never going down the wrong
track and he's committed the crime and I
was kind of thinking that in sticks are
very important as an actor as well
aren't they do you find it easy to trust
your own instincts and and have you
found that in your acting career
yes it's obviously you have to always
take risks and you have to but yeah yeah
we called more I think not it instinct
you'd like to listen to your stomach in
one way the feeling of it and that may
be similar to policeman and Peterson was
new to this particular part of the
series isn't here in both trial was it
like working with him it was great yeah
he is also born in the notice known as
Sweden so it was our first work together
and and it was great because it was a
really nice collaboration together with
us we were working every night
with the following scenes and try to
make this struggle that these two
characters has it's like two polar bears
in the end you know and really make it
it was really exciting I love to work
with them and of course you know
Scandinavian productions are really
receiving a lot of love and happen for a
while now in the english-speaking world
haven't they what do you think makes
Nordic mwah stand out for people no
maybe it's a I really don't know I think
it's a rock first of all it's very cool
name there's no didn't know how it
sounds really great but I think we have
a tradition of writing the authors that
started really in the in the end of the
60s with Percival and Sharon Waller the
the inspector backstories it's a
Trinette tradition to tomb to make
police stories place them really in the
society of today they started that
tradition and Henning Mankell keep on
doing it and a lot of more than I okay I
think it started there in the society
because they are quite specific in a way
to the Scandinavian countries but they
seem to work also for audiences outside
he might not have ever visited them or
know anything about every other debut at
all why do you think why do you think
that is maybe it's it's this you know
this little little country Sweden safe
we called it in the 70s default the
people's home for the polar the politics
call it the people's home and and
suddenly that is attacked by criminality
and some problem and maybe that's it's a
good way to tell the story I mean it
it's ordinary people who will really get
in trouble nobody will go to Easter no I
can't I can tell you all it's a its
meaning is the safe place in my way yeah
the next one is
in this actual attorney inspect a new
inspector we had shoot a Syrian now for
for about the mother wolf Palma and we
are planning to do two more
Sebastian environment oh I came to ask
if you entered any westenberg
and fantastic news and do you think
there might be a hunter 3 or the next
title after Falls Trail I they have to
do it before 16 years the heck can't
wait 16 years oh no no I don't think so
the end line under Falls Trail no I mean
the the the idea about about a hunter's
was it was made for the for the cinemas
it's not made for the television in that
way to make a serie of something it's a
movie for the cinema
you